foreign
[Music]
crime daily harrowing testimony from
student and teacher survivors of the
Parkland school shooting I kept thinking
about these kids that should not be
experiencing this at all and the
Doomsday cult Duo why prosecutors want
more DNA testing before the couple heads
to trial plus Colorado versus Kevin Dean
Eastman two people who were loved by
their family and friends lost their
lives but they didn't just die
they were brutally murdered any
investigation again became trying to
prove that it was Mr Eastman rather than
finding the truth here closing arguments
from both sides and later after weeks on
the run as a fugitive and plastic
surgery to alter her appearance Kalyn
Armstrong makes her first court
appearance in Texas law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily I'm
your host Brian Buckner disturbing and
graphic testimony is presented in the
Parkland school shooting penalty phase
trial
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when a then 19 year old gunman
opened fire and Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School in 2018. in October of last
year the shooter pled guilty to 17
Council of murder and 17 more counts of
attempted murder which prompted his case
to head straight into the penalty phase
a jury will now decide whether the
shooter is sentenced to life in prison
or given the death penalty on Wednesday
students and teachers alike testified
they believed the shooting to be a drill
until they were either shot themselves
or witnessed The Fallout others said
they thought the gunshots were possibly
Valentine's Day balloons popping in the
hallway
I remember hearing some shots outside
the room
recognizing the shots um
um no at first I thought it was just
balloons because everybody had balloons
because it was Valentine's Day okay so
what happened
after we heard about three shots we were
all like this is not normal so we
started to hide
and then after we hid we heard more okay
so that's when we knew this was serious
we all were sort of down on the ground
and we were on the on the floor trying
to hide behind whatever we could and it
was really seconds later that the barrel
of that AR-15 just ambushed our
classroom became right through that
glass door uh the glass panel in the
door excuse me and was just
shooting everywhere it was extremely
loud it was very frightening
um and I kept thinking about these kids
that should not be experiencing this at
all
joining us today is federal clemency
expert and legal analyst Tammy Allison
and co-host Terry Austin Tammy this
testimony is absolutely heart-wrenching
and it just started do you think this
would be how the whole trial goes with
the prosecution and do you think that's
their plan
yes I do think so Brian I think it's
very strategic for the prosecution to
have these types of witnesses testify
that to the type of fear that they
experienced the terror the fact that
they thought that it was a drill the
fact that it was Valentine's Day where
people were excited to get gifts
chocolate flowers balloons and they're
saying that they thought the sound was
balloons until they experienced getting
shot themselves or seeing someone else
get shot I think what it's going to do
is chip away at the defenses
um
High what the defense will try to do to
try to bring about mitigating factors
we've heard before that they want to
bring in his age in order to have a
lesser sentence for him but I think the
prosecution is doing a great job at
getting him the highest penalty during
this phase absolutely the prosecution is
laying down quite thick with all the
great facts they have Terry after this
school shooting in Parkland the
commission found that the police
response was slow and now we're hearing
the same reports and yovaldi in the
school shooting there in Texas what more
can be done to save lives in our schools
you know one of the things I think we
can do because we are seeing that the
police reaction is slow is making sure
these police officers are trained to
stop the threat and I think beyond that
we can also protect our schools maybe
the doors to the classrooms should be
bulletproof they should perhaps make
sure they check for weapons before they
come into the school making sure that
when you leave the school that the door
is automatically locked so there's a lot
that we can do to help our children here
well and a Connecticut detective is
penalized after allegedly mishandling a
premature death case last winter
Bridgeport detective Angel yanos was
initially cleared after an independent
Arbiter reviewed the death case of
Brenda Lee Rawls a black woman found
dead the morning after spending an
evening with a man she knew on the same
day last December 23 year old Lauren
Smithfield was also discovered dead
after the night with a different man
while the cases were unrelated both
women's families said they were not
notified by police and alleged
investigators were racially insensitive
both deaths were later ruled to be
accidental but sparked discussions of
police policy Janos along with Detective
Kevin Cronin were accused of failing to
properly notify Lee Rawls and
Smithfield's loved ones of their deaths
and later placed on administrative leave
the American Arbitration Association
investigation concluded earlier this
year giannos should it not have been
placed on leave ordering the sea to
reinstate him after an internal probe
the acting police chief penalized yanos
over the same manner stripping him of
two holidays which Lee rawl's family
argues isn't enough saying it seems like
a slap on the wrist
foreign
coast to California an unexpected delay
in the trial of Paul and Reuben Flores
the Father and Son charged in the murder
of Kristen smart smart went missing in
1996 when she was a student at
California Polytech State University she
was last seen with Paul Flores at an
off-campus party several days later she
was reported missing while Smart's
remains have never been found she was
legally declared dead in 2002. the case
went cold for years until the podcast
your own backyard reignited interest in
Smart's disappearance Paul and Ruben
Flores were later arrested prosecutor is
saying Smart's body was buried in their
yard but later moved Paul is charged
with Smart's murder while Reuben is
charged with accessory after the fact
accused of helping to hide Smart's body
opening statements began on Monday but
were unexpectedly delayed until Thursday
Court officials cited a health issue but
did not give specific details the
conclusion of opening statements and the
start of witness testimony is expected
for Thursday
foreign
crying daily closing arguments are
presented in Colorado where a man stands
trial for double murder but first we
look ahead to the trial of the so-called
doomsday cult Duo what evidence
prosecutors hope to test for DNA
[Music]
welcome back we're looking ahead now to
the trial of the so-called doomsday cult
Duo as prosky's requests DNA testing on
several pieces of evidence in the case
Lori valadebell and Chao dabel are
charged with multiple counts of
first-degree murder and conspiracy to
commit murder in the deaths of Lori's
children JJ and Tyler and Chad's first
wife Tammy dubbed the Doomsday cold Duo
because of their end of times belief
Lori and Chad marry in October of 2019
just two weeks after Tammy dabell's
death just one month before that Tyler
and JJ were seen for the last time their
bodies were found nearly one year later
on Chad dabell's property now as
prosecutors looking ahead to the
couple's coming trial they request DNA
testing on a series of evidence items
that includes a shovel and pickaxe here
is found in the body bag used to
transport JJ's body and a swab under
JJ's fingernails prosecutors asked for
consumptive testing on the items which
means they can only be tested once
before the evidence is destroyed so far
the cases judge has not made a ruling on
the motion Chad and Lori dable have pled
not guilty to all charges they are set
to be tried together in January of 2023.
Terry the property JJ and Tyler's bodies
were found on was Chad so it's likely
that his and Lori's DNA would be found
on or around the children's body but one
of the specific items they are looking
at that would be crucial to the
prosecution's case
Brian I think they're not going to focus
on the house because Chad and Loris
dinay will be all over the house so I
think what they're going to focus on is
the burn pit everything right outside
the house in that pit they're going to
look at that shovel the ax the body back
all of that is very critical I also
think they're going to look for other
matches not just Chad not just Lori but
also Lori's brother Alex remember his
phone pinged right at that property and
he disappeared right after
they died or they were found missing and
so I believe that they're going to also
be looking for Alex's DNA as well so
we'll see what happens but it's lots of
DNA that they're going to have to
investigate here yeah it'll be a whole
new Twist and Turn if Alex's DNA is the
hair in the body bag Tammy the defense
block the testing once because the tasks
would use up all the DNA so how will the
testing or how could the testing be
conducted going forward
you know the testing could be conducted
going forward on a stipulation from both
the prosecution and the defense if they
can come to some type of an agreement as
to what can be allowed in that is what
could move it forward but it doesn't
seem like that's going to happen here so
they're going to have to rely on other
types of evidence in order to meet their
burden
um or to raise Reasonable Doubt so that
you know their clients can be hopefully
found not guilty that's what the defense
attorneys want but the prosecution is
going to really want to present all of
the relevant evidence so that they can
sustain that conviction of guilty yeah
we'll see how this plays out as to how
and whether this DNA comes in and the
procedures that follow in New York
charges are dropped against the bodega
worker originally facing a second degree
murder charge for stabbing an attacker
the charges down from a July first
incident caught on camera 61 year old
Jose Alba was working behind the counter
when Austin Simon stormed into the store
when a fight broke out Alba grabbed a
knife and stabbed Simon three times
Simon died as a result Alba was arrested
and held on a quarter of a million
dollars Bond after that public outcry
called for Alba to be released as many
argue he acted in self-defense on
Tuesday a judge dismissed Alba's murder
charge after an investigation by the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office
found the case lacked the evidence to
proceed
also on the East Coast so mountain
police chase caught on camera take a
look NYPD posted this body cam footage
of social media this week showing a cop
on Horseback chasing an accused robbery
suspect through the streets of New York
it all started when a vendor near Times
Square told the cop several pairs of
sunglasses had been stolen the 34 year
old suspect is seen on body cameras
speaking with the officer then he turns
and runs the officer follows after him
Galloping over sewer grades and against
traffic toward the end of the video you
see other officers step in as a suspect
is arrested he is charged with robbery
menacing and criminal possession of a
weapon nypd's commissioner posted on
Twitter is saying there was no chance he
could outrun the 10-foot cop riding
Samson
coming up on Law and crying daily after
weeks on the Run of fugitive and accused
killer makes her first court appearance
plus hear from both sides as closing
arguments are presented in the case of
Colorado versus Kevin Dean Acer
[Music]
welcome back close the arguments are
presented in the Colorado double
homicide trial of Kevin Dean Eastman
Eastman is charged with two counts of
first-degree murder tampering with a
deceased human body and tampering with
physical evidence for allegedly killing
his ex-girlfriend Heather Frank and her
new love interest local musician Stanley
Scott sessions officials say the two
were killed on separate days in February
of 2020. Eastman allegedly killed in
sessions by cutting his throat inside
Frank's apartment Frank and Eastman both
had arrest warrants in connection to
sessions murder until Frank's body was
found investigators believe Eastman
fatally shot Frank to silence the only
witness to sessions killing they say he
then hit her body wrapped in a plastic
near a burn pile on the rural property
where he worked Eastman allegedly burned
sessions body and prepared to burn
Frank's Body when he was arrested at a
nearby gas station in closing arguments
the prosecutor said the near-death
collapsing evidence proves Eastman had
the motives to kill sessions and Frank
they argue that this case is about
domestic violence saying several
witnesses back on the claim Eastman
abused Frank
soon after he shows up
in Greeley
two people who were loved by their
family and friends lost their lives but
they didn't just die
they were brutally murdered
Scott sessions was nearly decapitated
within a week Heather Frank
was found in that condition
shot to the heart area twice one
ambushed
one shot to the heart
coincidence
away
at the beginning
of this case like I said we introduced
the concept of domestic violence because
at its core that's what this case is
about interestingly Scott sessions
likely never heard the name Kevin
Eastman
and certainly never met him
at least face to face
because he didn't give him that chance
but at its core this is a story of a
long-term domestic violence relationship
playing out to its predictably tragic
end
Eastman's defense attorney once again
pointing the finger at Frank being
responsible for sessions death and said
Troy bonnell's Eastman's employer killed
Frank
law enforcement made assumptions as soon
as they learned that Miss Frank had an
ax an ax with whom she had a volatile
relationship
they assumed and it became this Catalyst
moment they assumed that's our guy
and the investigation began became
trying to prove that it was Mr Eastman
rather than finding the truth as an
eximus Frank Mr Eastman made an easy
target for an accusation built on
assumptions
but he did not kill Mr sessions he did
not kill Miss Frank
Miss Frank killed Mr sessions and Mr
Eastman helped in the aftermath as did
Mr Bonnell
and then Mr Bonnell panicked he worried
about his help after the fact
implicating him in Mr session's death he
took matters into his own hands and he
killed Miss Frank concealing her body on
his property
Terry the evidence seems heavily
weighted against Eastman where do you
think the jury stands at this point
you know I don't think it's going to
take this jury long to deliberate the
evidence is very heavy against the
defendant here and I listened to the
prosecution's closing I thought it was
excellent he said that the defense made
assumptions well they started out with
assumptions then they followed the
evidence and all of the evidence points
to the fact that Eastman was jealous and
that he attacked Scott sessions the
weight of that knife against his throat
the fact that it was so vicious and so
personal no question about it it was him
and then it wasn't Heather Frank either
because she did live through that
domestic violence and she herself was
killed so I do think it'll be a short
deliberation and I think that it'll come
back as a guilty word yeah interesting
but can Sammy on the other side the
question is does the Troy Bonnell and
Frank alternative suspect argument hold
water for you
you know it doesn't really hold water
for me but I'm not the person that it
needs to hold water for it needs to hold
water for the jury
um because what that does is it raises
gout and you know the prosecution's
burden is that very high burden of
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt so any type of
doubt that's raised could in fact result
in the jury coming back with the not
guilty verdict if in fact they are
believing that alternative Theory all
right we'll see what is going on as as
this jury continues to deliberate as to
what their decision will be in this the
Colorado versus Kevin Dean Eastman trial
when we come back a fugitive almond run
and accused killer now appears in court
for the first time we lived in Texas
where the case of Caitlyn Armstrong
begins to take shape
foreign
[Music]
crime daily a Texas yoga teacher accused
of murder makes her first court
appearance where she pleads not guilty
to allegedly killing a professional
cyclist 34 year old Armstrong was
arrested in Costa Rica June 29th for her
involvement in the shooting death of Mo
Wilson after investigators say she fled
the country Wilson whose real name is
Anna Mariah was shot and killed more
than 40 days earlier on May 11th
investigators say she may have dated
Caitlin Armstrong's boyfriend while the
two were broken up though the boyfriend
maintains it was a platonic relationship
investigators say Armstrong used someone
else's passport to flee to Costa Rica
once there Armstrong altered her
appearance by dying her hair darker and
undergoing plastic surgery after her
arrest Armstrong was brought back to the
United States and booked into the Travis
County Jail in Austin Texas on a three
and a half million dollar bond in court
Wednesday Armstrong's attorneys entered
a plea of not guilty and filed a motion
for a speedy trial the judge said it
dated in October for the trial to begin
Timmy what is his first appearance for
Armstrong mean as in terms of the next
steps for her case
well the first appearance is a chance
for her to know what she's being charged
for what she is actually being alleged
of doing so that is typically the
arraignment so she has a chance to enter
a plea of guilty or not guilty bond is
typically set and from there she will
probably remain incarcerated given the
fact that she fled before and there are
procedural things that happen between
the prosecutors and the defense
including plea negotiations and if that
does not result in anything
um most likely it would go to trial yeah
and Tara part of that is exchanging of
Discovery investigation things of that
with a case this complicated spanning
three states and two continents the
investigation is going to be massive so
what kind of evidence should we expect
in a case like this
well you know Brian you're absolutely
correct it will be a huge massive
investigation and it will be spanning
over a couple of states and over a
couple of continents and it's going to
hinge on forensics she escaped to Costa
Rica so she went through Austin to New
York to New Jersey than Costa Rica you
better believe that authorities are
going to go through all of that they're
going to be looking for video cameras
what does that show did she meet with
someone what happened to the gun did she
drop it off in any one of those
locations and did someone else help her
they'll be looking at phone records also
I think it's going to have tons and tons
of that type of evidence in this case to
make a determination as to what actually
happened we don't even know yet whether
or not they have found that gun they're
going to look at ballistics to see what
happened as far as the shots to mow to
the victim and so I definitely think
it's going to take some time and I think
that for that time we know she's going
to be in jail because the bond was set
at such a high amount yeah finally that
gun's probably going to be the first
thing that law enforcement is going to
look for but Tammy and Terry thank you
very much and thank you for joining us
here on Law and crying daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]